aggressive yeah why you being aggressive
I'm not aggressive the problem
is the problem is the problem is this
what you're doing is
guys I mean because the men are usually
more logical than women just from this
conversation you said okay wait wa wait
because I'll give you I'll give you an
example you said one thing he said the
same thing back to you you don't like
how he said it disrespectful it's
disrespectful to say exactly it's
disrespectful to say exactly what you
said but see it's so funny cuz this is
what they do we're not talking about me
right now we're talking about you I'm
talking and it's so and it's so
interesting because you know what they
do it's like you you say one thing and
then he says it back to you and then you
get mad no